it becomes a part of your daily life you
know sometimes you just can't leave a
good role Behind These are 15 method
actors who stayed in character while on
set I did stay in character on set with
everybody number one it's hard not to
lose yourself in the dark for his role
in Dahmer showrunner Ryan Murphy said
that Evan Peters stayed in character for
months one of the hardest things I've
ever had to do in my life he created a
45-minute audio composite of Dahmer's
voice that he listened to every day to
get his speech patterns right I'm just
trying to say I'm sorry
you're gonna open your gift
and to nail Dahmer's rigid posture he
wore lead weights in his shoes and
around his arms Evan Peters has spoken
about how much he appreciated the crew's
support comparing them to being a ray of
light amidst the darkness I felt like
everybody was so protective you know all
of you guys when we were working
together I felt very comfortable and
safe number two Lady Gaga has a great
Poker Face she felt as though she'd
truly lived as reggiana for a year and a
half while filming House of Gucci and
she spoke with an Italian accent for
nine months even among her own family on
the phone I would have spoken to you
just like this director Ridley Scott
said that he almost forgot those weren't
her real mannerisms
this is serious but there were some
negative side effects close to the end
of filming Lady Gaga went for a walk
through Italy and as she described it I
panicked I thought I was on a movie set
number three you couldn't even call her
Nicole Nicole Kidman told a television
critics Association panel that she'd
only respond to Masha on the set for
nine perfect strangers she said that she
wanted a very calm healing energy to
emanate all the time and so she
remembers going over to people and sort
of putting my hand on their heart or
holding their hand on set when James
Corden asked if she would act like Masha
at home she answered sometimes at home
yeah
don't ask number four it's tough being
the boss Meryl Streep never broke
character on set for the Devil Wears
Prada and she was so miserable that
she'd Proclaim that's the last time I
ever attempted a method thing Emily
Blunt would say that Merrell is so
gregarious and fun that it was a bit of
a letdown her having to remove herself
Anne Hathaway admitted that she found
Streep intimidating but said she
appreciated her guidance because I also
knew she was watching out for me she's
uh very generous you know she was not I
don't think scared of me number five
this role had him All Shook Up Austin
Butler had to go to the hospital the day
after filming finished for Elvis
claiming that he woke up with
excruciating pain and he suffered a bit
of an identity crisis afterwards to
London to have to film something else
and I was just going I don't know who I
am I don't know what's going on
apparently his voice had changed so much
for the role that he told GQ my family
said I didn't sound like me anymore but
Butler admits that he still listens to
plenty of Elvis music adding I've never
loved somebody I've never met more than
Elvis number 6. Ashton Kutcher spent
three months living like Steve Jobs he
read all the books that jobs loved
agonized over the walk and even followed
Steve Jobs fruitarian diet which would
apparently sometimes consist of nothing
but grapes Ashton Kutcher wound up going
to the hospital twice with pancreatitis
two weeks before filming had even
started like the ghost of Steve Jobs is
like taking over my face but fortunately
he had Mila Kunis to get him back on
track so fact check yes it was really
dumb number 7. Joaquin Phoenix went So
Meta he tanked his own career the
mockumentary I'm still here follows his
own retirement from acting and
subsequent launch into hip-hop but most
people who heard about it thought he was
actually retiring not only that but the
movie bombed so badly he wouldn't act
again for another two years still
Phoenix went on to refer to the
mockumentary as an amazing experience
explaining that it allowed me to be bold
in my decisions instead of being safe
number eight she may have gotten a
little carried away Margot Robbie told
vulture that there was a time on set for
I Tonya where I genuinely forgot that we
were on a film set and that I wasn't
Tanya and that he wasn't Jeff referring
to Sebastian Stan she went on to
describe a time that the two of them
were acting out a brawl and they were
just so in character that she'd later
recall to Sebastian Stan I think I
punched you in the side of the head I
think we kind of lost our minds
sometimes on set number nine you
probably shouldn't follow Christian
Bale's diet tips he lost 63 pounds for
his role in The Machinist living on a
diet of black coffee a can of tuna and
an apple a day immediately afterward he
bulked up for his role in Batman Begins
admitting that he was ignoring advice
about taking it slowly Bale's weight
would continue to fluctuate for multiple
roles afterward even jumping to 228
pounds for American Hustle but he's
since told Men's Health I've become a
little bit more boring now because I'd
prefer not to die number 10. beauty
isn't easy for My Week with Marilyn
Michelle Williams practiced walking like
Marilyn Monroe by tying a belt around
her knees and going around wearing tight
dresses high heels and push-up bras she
binge watched her movies read Maryland's
autobiographies and even downloaded
interviews with Marilyn onto her iPod to
listen to for months but this did come
with its emotional cost Michelle
Williams would tell Newsweek I don't
think I ever cried so much for somebody
I didn't know number 11. this role
almost made her quit Angelina Jolie
preferred to stay in character at all
times during her earlier career but this
took its toll during the filming of Gia
Angelina distanced herself from then
husband Johnny Lee Miller telling him
I'm alone I'm dying I'm gay I'm not
going to see you for weeks she even
briefly gave up acting afterward feeling
that she had nothing else to give
looking back on the role years later
Angelina would say I was so sad for her
playing a real person you identify with
and can feel makes you feel a
responsibility number 12. the end
credits were a right to list Teddy
Perkins as himself Donald Glover
immersed himself so much into the role
of Teddy Perkins for episode 6 of
Atlanta that co-star Derek a wood hardly
even recognized him telling vulture
there was no Donald on set whatsoever I
kid you not Teddy Perkins even made an
appearance in the crowd at the Emmys
prompting tweets like did I just see
Donald Glover as Teddy Perkins at the
Emmys but as of yet the identity of the
actor is yet to be confirmed number 13.
he became an entirely different person
Jim Carrey would say that during the
four months of filming for man on the
moon pretty much from when I woke up to
when I went to bed the choices were all
kauffmans co-star Paul Giamatti would
recall it as one of the weirdest
experiences I've had making a movie he
said that Carrie would keep Limburger
cheese in his pockets and that he was
constantly touching and hugging people
on set with the smelly cheese on his
hands number 14. imagine being on set
with a military dictator for his role in
The Last King of Scotland Forest
Whitaker spent three months living in
Uganda learning to speak Swahili and
even spent time living with IDI Amin's
Family David oyelowo referred to
Whitaker's tendency to remain in
character both on and offset as a
nightmare recalling one incident when he
met him in a Ugandan hotel and I said oh
hi Forrest and he went
literally but end of day he added that
the performance was worth it number 15.
Kate Winslet is no stranger to method
acting it apparently took her months to
get over her role from the reader saying
it's like I've escaped from a serious
car accident and need to understand what
has just happened but it was her role in
ammonite that may have taken things too
far this time Winslet lived in an
isolated cabin during filming describing
it as so ratty and cold that she'd lie
there thinking Kate what are you doing
just go to the hotel with everybody else
you can plainly see how all of these
actors care deeply for their craft which
actors methods did you think were the
most extreme make sure to let us know in
the comments